so I wanted to come back to this paper
here about the long former I have done a
video on this if you haven't seen it
then this video is probably not going to
make much sense to you but in the video
I go over what the long former is what
it does how it compares and so on and
the gist of the long former is that it
can now do a transformer model on a long
document as you can read here so I've
gotten a lot of questions of like does
that mean we can now have much longer
documents right the bird model doesn't
fit into my memory can this solve my
problem and I just kind of want to go
into the math of the long form or memory
requirements here because I think I've
alluded to it but it is it is quite a a
I think the graphics here are just a bit
misleading from the way they implement
it
now I've already gone over something
like this in the last thing so Roberta
row let's spell this correctly Roberta
that is their baseline has a a size a
let's call that n 0 of 512 so they can
have 512 tokens at the same time so if
you have a sequence that is way longer
than 512 you need to chunk it up into
pieces of 512 and usually do something
like overlapping pieces or something
like this right and now the promise of
the long former as it is in the paper is
that you can put all of this into the
long former right and it will do this
sliding window attention thing where it
basically slides a window here this
window across this input sequence and
only does this local attention right
within the window and then it also has
some
global attention that it constantly has
now what I find interesting is that in
their experiments their window size here
so the long former window size is 512
right so within that window you have the
classic N squared full attention so
right so let's just go in into into that
how much memory does the long former
really do we've already calculated it
here a bit but I want to take this still
apart a bit so as you can see on the
left here you have n times W that you
have for this middle band right so this
middle band is n times W then you want
to add the global attention right so the
global attention you can already see it
right here if you have one two three
four locations of global attention you
have four times two because you also
have them in this direction like you
have them in both directions times your
full sequence length so plus two times
full sequence length length times the
number of global attention I call this s
over here so as we saw up here the
window size here was and zero in their
experiments so let's replace this window
size by n 0 and actually let's factor
out the N so we'll get 2 n times n 0 + 2
s
all right so you can already see that
Roberta originally had n zero squared
now if n is larger than n zero that
means you already use more here the the
kind of trick let's it's not really a
trick it is true that this is order of n
all right if n is your input sequence
length but and this here is technically
order of N squared if n if this is n but
the sequence length in Roberta was the
was the window size of the long former
so this is n zero squared and here
technically you'd have to say this is n
times n zero so if n is larger than n
zero you can see that this uses more
memory given that so in their
experiments they use a model that on
paper uses more memory than the baseline
model and saying that it it scales
linearly with sequence length is because
I mean of course it scales linearly
because they can now input these long
sequences right and the attention sorry
the memory requirements scales basically
linear and also linear with the window
size now the window size still needs to
be apparently large ish in order to
achieve the performance so the fact that
the performance is equal or better is
not really a secret because it uses more
memory it's not like this model uses
less memory but outperforms the old one
it uses more
if you want to look at it you have to
ask okay
I have Roberto and right now I can do N
squared so this is n this is n there's n
0 and 0 this is my sequence length that
I can put into Roberto you have to ask
yourself what kind of sequence do I want
to put in and if you say I want to put
in a sequence that's twice as long right
I want to put in this long of a sequence
so n here would be twice n 0 then you
have to take this put it here put it
here and then you realize yes that your
window size your of the long former can
only be half right so if you have the
same amount of memory you can double
your sequence length at the cost of
having your having your window size but
that doesn't yet include the cost of the
global attention so any global attention
you do will come basically on top of the
window size you see this here right so
the you decide on let's do it like this
you decide on how long you want your
thing your your input sequence length to
be then you decide then that means
that's this rectangle here then you
decide how many global attentions do I
want and here I say I want one global
attention and you have to cross out as
many rows here as you want global
attention and what remains is your
windows actually have to cross out twice
but we don't have we only have one left
but you get the point you have to cross
out 2 times s rows of how many global
attentions you want and what remains
will be your window size in this case
it's just a window size of 1 so that's
how you would construct a long 4
that takes in the same amount of memory
as a your classic model but can take a
full n sequence length alright so I just
wanted to kind of make that clear go
through the calculation myself and I
hope that helped
thanks for listening and if you like
this consider subscribing like King and
bye bye